نقلت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه عن وزراء
الكبار في الحكومه الاسرائيليه قولهم ان
مجلس الحرب لن يدوم طويلا وان هناك محاوله
لتحميل المؤسسه الامنيه مسؤوليه الفشل في
السابع من اكتوبر كما نقلت الهيئه عن
الوزراء الاسرائيليين ان الهجوم على رئيس
الاركان خطه له بالتنسيق مع رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو نقلت القناه الثانيه عش
الاسرائيليه عن مسؤولين في الجيش قولهم
انهم يحاربون في غزه ولبنان والضفه
الغربيه في وقت يحاربهم مجلس الوزراء في
الداخل واضافت القناه نقلا عن مصادر في
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان وزير الدفاع يواف
جالنت يعتقد ان رئيس الاركان هيرتز هاليفي
اخطا حين شكل فريق التحقيق قبل ان يستشيره
لاسما ان وزير الدفاع سمع بقرار تشكيل
لجنه التحقيق في هجوم السابع من اكتوبر
قبل دقائق من جلسه مجلس
الوزراء ال الجدل بشان التحقيقات
والخلافات التي اشير اليها في مؤتمر
المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي قبل قليل
نتابعها مع مراسله الجزيره نجوان سمري من
تل ابيب
نجوان نعم بالفعل والجو في اسرائيل حاليا
يذكر بنفس الاجواء التي سادت قبل ثلاثه
اشهر قبل بدايه هذه الحرب محمود مع
الانقسامات التي شهد الشارع الاسرائيلي
وايضا
ال الكنيست والحكومه على اثر التغييرات
القضائيه التي ارادت حكومه نتنياهو ان
تجريها على المنظومه القضائيه وشهدت تل
ابيب واسرائيل بشكل عام مظاهرات لاكثر من
تسعه اشهر ما وحد ربما الشارع الاسرائيلي
او اوقف هذه التظاهرات ضد الحكومه وضد
التغييرات القضائيه كانت بدايه الحرب على
غز غزه وهناك من يشير اليوم بعد ثلاثه
اشهر من الحرب ان هذه الوحده بشان الحرب
على غزه التي وحدت الشارع الاسرائيلي نوعا
ما دامت فقط لثلاثه اشهر وها هي بدات هذه
الخلافات تعود الى المستوى السياسي والى
المستوى على مستوى الشارع ايضا لان كل ما
يحدث في الحكومه وفي مجلس الحرب
وفي المجلس الامني الوزاري المصغر ينعكس
بشكل مباشر
بطبيعه الحال على الخطاب في الشارع
الاسرائيلي وهناك يعني يحدث مباشره نوع من
الاستقطاب من هم الى جانب الاحزاب
اليمينيه المتطرفه الذين هاجموا عمليا
القياده العسكريه وهرتي هاليفي ومن هم
بطبيعه الحال يعتبرون مع المعارضه ومع من
التف حول القياده العسكريه ضد القياده
السياسيه في هذا السياق تحديدا يعني هذا
ال اليوم نسمع من الجيش الاسرائيلي يعني
نقلت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان ضباط
ومسؤولون في الجيش الاسرائيلي يقولون
بانهم في الوقت الذي يخذون فيه حربا على
جبهات متعدده في الشمال وفي غزه فان
الكابينه الاسرائيلي المجلس الوزاري
الامني والسياسي المصغر يخوض حربا ضد
الجيش وفي هذا التصريح الكثير من المؤشرات
التي تؤكد عمق الازمه ازمه الثقه ما بين
القياده العسكريه والقياده السياسيه في
اسرائيل ربما بدات
بالتهجم الليله الماضيه على رئيس هيئه
اركان الجيش خلال الاجتماع للمجلس الوزاري
الامني المصغر من قبل اتمار بين كفير
وبتسل س موتتش ولكن ايضا من قبل اعضاء في
حزب الليكود يعتبرون مقربون جدا يعتبرون
مقربين جدا من بنيامين نتنياهو الوزيره
ميري ريجف والوزير دودي ام سالم شاركوا في
بهذا التهجم وفقا للتسريبات اي يعني
وبالتالي هذا ال التهجم الذي بدا على
ايه على هيرتي هاليفي بدا اليوم يقرا بانه
كان جزء من محاولات القياده السياسيه وعلى
راسها بنيامين نتنياهو التنصل من
المسؤوليه بالكامل عن اخفاق السابع من
اكتوبر بل وتحميل المسؤوليه فقط للقياده
العسكريه والانتقادات الواسع اليوم على
هذه على هذا السلوك في الاجتماع تحديدا في
النقاشات وفي ال التحليلات السياسيه في
اسرائيل الصحافه الاسرائيليه طيله هذا
النهار تغطي هذا الموضوع ولكنها تنتقد هذا
التهجم على هيرتي هاليفي يقولون بان
نتنياهو لم يصمت خلال هذا الاجتماع فحسب
لن لم يستمتع فقط وفقا لما وصف في واحده
من وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه قالوا بانه
جلس واستمتع بهذا التهجم ولكنه ايضا دعم
هذا التهجم على هيرتي هاليفي لانه في
نهايه ال الجلسه قال توجه لهرس هاليفي
وقال له يجدر بك الاستماع الى هذه
الانتقادات من الوزراء وبالتالي هو لم يكن
محايدا في هذا ال الجدال وفي هذا السجال
الذي دار وبالتالي هناك اليوم من قرا بانه
ساهم وشجع هذا التهجم على ال ال
على هرت هاليفي الذي يمثل بطبيعه الحال
راس الهرم والقياده العسكريه في اسرائيل
في خضم حرب المشكله بالنسبه ل لمن ينتقد
ما حدث الليله الماضيه ان كل ذلك يحدث في
خضم حرب يجدر بالجانب السياسي تقديم كل
الدعم للقياده العسكريه لذلك سمعنا دانييل
هاجار في مؤتمره الصحفي او في البيان الذي
ادلى به هذه الليله وهو
ناطق المفروض ان يتحدث عن سير العمليات في
غزه راينا هذه الليله بانه اختار ان يتحدث
تحديدا عن قضيه تشكيل هيرتي هاليفي لفريق
من الذين من فريق من الخبراء الامنيين
السابقين او المسؤولين الامنيين السابقين
للتحقيق فيما حدث يوم السابع من اكتوبر
على مستوى الجيش الاخفاق بالنسبه للجنود
الاسرائيليين في صد هذا الهجوم وحاول ان
يبرر بان هذا التحقيق سيكون عملياتي فحسب
ولن يستبدل تحقيقات رسميه اخرى وهذا ياتي
في الرد ايضا على اتهامات من قبل القياده
السياسيه بان تشكيل هذا الفريق من قبل
هيرسي هاليفي في هذا التوقيت بالذات هو
اولا لاجبار القياده السياسيه ايضا على
تشكيل ايه فريق للتحقيق في الفشل السياسي
في هذا الموضوع من جهه ولكن ايضا من اجل
محاوله تبرئه القياده العسكريه من
المسؤوليه والقاء المسؤوليه على الجانب
السياسي